We got a request from a group of line dancers
in Rockaway, New Jersey, check it out!
Hi, Drew!
We're a group of friends from Rockaway, New Jersey
who loved to go out line dancing.
We love our girls nights out
because they keep us sane, it's great exercise, super fun,
and a huge stress relief.
We absolutely love you and your show.
And our dream is to have you join us
for girls night out of line dancing and good time.
Please join us, Drew!
(women cheering)
Well, after seeing that video,
we reached out to line dancing of Rockaway
and they sent their best instructor
to teach us how to dance.
Please, welcome.
Samantha Yahnke.
Hi Drew, it's so fabulous to meet you.
Thanks for having us.
Put on my tightest jeans for you.
You look fabulous.
Thank you.
You're rocking the full denim.
I'm sucking it in like nobody's business.
(Drew laughs)
Well, you're rocking it.
Thank you.
So you come out, you look effortless like.
So how is it going?
Okay.
Now, you know.
I have to admit I've only been line dancing once,
and I really liked didn't have anyone to teach me.
What is line dancing and how did it get started?
So line dancing is pretty much,
it's an organized set of steps typically by eight counts.
And you're all standing in a line with your friends,
doing the same steps, having a good time.
And you're all doing the same choreographed moves.
So I'm excited to learn today.
But what fun is line dancing without a partner?
Rossy, you there?
(crowd cheering)
Ladies.
(Drew laughing)
My jeans are so tight, Drew, never in my life.
Do not drop anything 'cause I can't pick it up.
(Drew laughs)
It's like Spanx by Wrangler.
(Ross laughs)
I wish!
You might be on to something there.
Full denim Spanx by Wrangler.
Right?
Why not?
Ross and I were inspired to bring it for you.
And Samantha, okay.
So now that we're dressed the part.
teach us how to do this.
We're your students now.
Beautiful.
So the dance we're doing, it's gonna start by walking.
I'm gonna be walking, I'll be facing this way.
Pardon me.
(Drew laughs)
And we're walking.
Okay, so weights on our left foot.
Okay.
Let's start with the one on the left.
Yep, we're taking three steps forward.
Walk forward, right.
Walk, left.
Walk, right.
Kick your left foot forward.
Kick.
We're now gonna walk straight back, three steps.
Walk back, left, walk back, right, walk back, left.
Touch your right toe next to it, there's no weight.
So you're right back where you started from.
Oh yeah.
Do the same exact thing again.
Three steps forward.
Walk, right, left, right.
Kickback, left, right, left, touch.
That's half your dance.
(audience cheering)
That's half your dance!
Drew, are we natural?
(everyone laughs)
All right.
The next piece.
Step touches.
They're exactly what they sound like.
Step forward on your right foot.
Touch your left toe, come out to the side.
And touch, there's no weight on it.
Step forward on your left, point your right.
Do them again, step forward, right.
Point your left.
Okay.
Step forward, left, point your right.
I can do that.
Yeah?
Okay, yeah.
Okay.
Let's try.
Let's try it from the top.
There's only one piece left, weights on our left.
Remember it starts with the walks.
Ready with the right.
It's right, left, right.
Kick back left.
Right, left, touch.
Again, right, left, right, kickback, left.
Step, point, step, point, step, point, step, point.
Nice!
(crowd cheering)
Ross!
I saw it, I saw it, I saw it!
Samantha, you're such a good teacher!
You guys are great students.
Oh thank you!
I'd like to finish it, shall we?
Yeah.
All right.
Quarter turn jazz box.
It sounds way more fancy than it is.
I know, it's okay.
Is it like a box step?
Yes!
Okay.
We're making a turn to our right when we do it.
So take that right foot, cross it over.
Step back on your left foot, making that turn.
If you didn't quite make it step the right foot
out to the side, you're done.
Step the left foot together.
The last bit of the dance, we get to shake it.
Bump your hips, right, left, right, left.
Okay.
I just wanna shake it.
All right.
Tony, would you hit us with a little music?
Please and thank you?
(music starts)
You wanna be faster.
Five, six, seven, go!
Right, left, right, kickback, back, back, touch.
Step point, step point, step point, cross it over,
turn to the side.
Step, shake it and repeat it now, right, left, right, kick.
Too fast!
That's faster!
(everyone clapping)
It was faster.
That was, you didn't prepare me for that!
Surprise!
All right, one more time.
You count us out, Samantha.
Okay, okay.
Okay, thank you.
Right, weight's on our left.
Okay.
One, three, five, six, seven, eight.
It's right, left, right, kick back, left,
right, left, touch, walk, right, left, right, kick back.
Left, right, left, touch.
We step, point, step, point, step point.
Now, right over left, cross turn, sidestep,
shake it, shake it, shake it, stop.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, beautiful!
(audience applause)
Thank you for giving us a feet that wasn't, you know,
like a jack rabbit on steroids.
Thank you so much.
I mean.
Of course.
That was really fun!
I know, right?
Okay, on a scale of one to 10,
where do we lie on the natural at line dancing scale?
Honestly, you guys are up there.
You guys are, I would give you a 10.
Okay, thank you so much.
Aw, Samantha.
You are so kind.
We got a 10 Drew.
All right, so we're not so bad.
And Drew, I invited the line dancing group from that video
to watch us today.
Hello!
(crowd cheers)
How are you doing?
Hi!
(everyone cheering)
(Drew blowing kisses)
Oh hi, girls!
Hi ladies!
How did we do, thumbs up?
(everyone cheering)
I thank you so much, ladies,
for allowing us to come into your world.
And thank you for all that you're putting out there.
Now, if anyone's watching in the VFS or at home,
and you want to vote for me to try a special talent,
or just be goofy or learn something
or put in some bizarre, interesting scenario,
write it into our show, and go to our show's website
and vote for Drew does.
And you know what?
I'll try anything.
(upbeat music)